kelly ripa will be at work tomorrow she
emailed the staff on Friday that she
will be and Michael told fan today but
now her BFF Andy Cohen has us wondering
Kelly is back but buckle up will it be a
bumpy ride all smiles on the set this
morning with Michael and fill-in host
Shay Mitchell Tran immediately
addressing who wasn't in the room she's
gonna be back tomorrow which we're all
excited about so does that sound excited
sources at live do tell us that Strahan
will be there with replaces between you
and me as for Kelly she confirmed her
return in a letter to the staff late
Friday following her one scheduled and
two unscheduled days off saying quote I
wanted to thank you all for giving me
the time to process this new information
we are a family and I look forward to
seeing you all on Tuesday morning well
tomorrow morning should be very
interesting because the source tells the
et that Al's off today
Michael and Kelly had still not talked
Ripa allegedly won't take his calls also
the source says the two will sit
together through May and then he'll
leave and the hunt for a new co-host
begins one person is still in shock
about string and leaving is Kelly's
bestie Andy Cohen who vented today on
his Sirius XM radio show it just seems
like a premature end to a great
relationship and it was a big bad
breakup how you leave the greatest job
in TV to be one of five people that's
what I couldn't get over